the Joe Rogan experience I think you're
right about the racism in terms of like
the attitude about crack versus cocaine
and that could clearly be demonstrated
by its sentencing ya know people were
sentenced the mandatory minimums for
crack crack use yeah I was so much
higher when people got caught with crack
or selling crack I mean they went to
jail for a long [ __ ] time whereas
people got caught with cocaine they
didn't go to jail for as long and the
treatment there the the sentence is much
smaller and dr. Carhart you know yeah
yeah he's great he's great as well I've
had him on here and he was explaining
he's like look there is no difference
yeah I was like it is cocaine like this
is cocaine yeah you want to break it
down to the drug effect on the body they
are the same thing and yeah one of them
sends you away for a long time one of
them does yeah well for my book about
West Coast hip-hop called original
gangsters
I interviewed Freeway Ricky Ross here
yes couple times yeah so he original
Rick Ross the original Rick Ross exactly
and he his sort of the innovation of
their era was I was called ready Rock
and so before people would people
preferred to smoke cocaine even before
crack was invented freebase that was
very exact Richard Pryor got in trouble
with yeah exactly
so the innovation was to make it so you
didn't have to freebase it was ready to
smoke so they called it ready rock and
easy ease first record label that is
called his record label was called
ruthless but they were gonna call it
rock house records you know for that
reason and so he was uh he was a crack
dealer before you got in the music
industry yeah the rick ross story is for
the real rick ross story I should say
and Rick Ross Freeway Ricky which is
with the east column was making millions
and millions of dollars did not have any
idea that he was involved in that whole
all of them conscious yeah it's just
incredible yeah they were using the
cocaine money to fund the the war with
the consciousness and in ystös yeah it's
yeah Rick Ross is a
I wrote about him and so I ended up
actually playing tennis with him because
I was really good tennis player yeah I
heard he was a and I was a big high
school tennis player too so I was like
let's do this and he's you know he's got
some years on me I don't know how old he
I think he's maybe late 50s but he was
he was holding his own we played in like
a south central a tennis court somewhere
and he he took some games off me that
well his story is incredible because
they sent him away on the three-strikes
rule for life and then while he was in
jail he learned how to read learned how
to understand the law and he started
like literally taught himself to be a
lawyer and then realize like no the way
they used the law was incorrect and
unlawful they the three-strikes means
you get arrested for larceny you get out
you get a last rest they did it in one
swoop so they gave him two charges at
the same time and put him in for three
strikes and he was able to successfully
prove that that was wrong that's why
he's out right now Wow
he he's so smart one of the things he
taught me that you know you guys hear
about crack babies all the time and he's
like cover of Newsweek babies he was
like you know crack babies aren't real
that's not a real thing he said that his
I believe I hope I'm not speaking out of
school I think like his wife like maybe
smoke crack while his son was in utero
never had any problems and he's like
yeah look around do do your research
click crack babies is not a real thing
that's crazy because I remember hearing
that as well at crack babies were the
thing we're all worried about in the 80s
oh my god wait till the year 2000 all
these crack babies are 20 years old yeah
I know yeah where are they now maybe
they're mumble rappers because you
understand real rap music these days I'm
definitely that's who I am
[Applause]